one of the things that puzzles me the
most about this is like why in the world
like these days this issue is getting
political and it's getting politic like
and and and I'm just like wh why do you
think that is like what like do you have
any insight into that like why you think
this is
becoming like a and maybe the answer is
just because [__] everything is but
there's like nothing I mean there's no
greater example of like what real evil
is you know people who are combating
against evil like I in your mind do do
you have any do you have any sort of
like insight to that or do you have any
thesis on why that is why this is
getting so politicized I don't know man
I think my my guess is like people just
have this tendency especially if you're
trying to get elected or stay elected or
you know we've really U leaned towards
this kind of like a it's a definition of
a bully right like instead of talking
about like the great things I'm going to
do we're going to talk about the the bad
things that other you talk [__] about
people which make us looks better like
to me like reminds me of like a middle
school bully or something right exactly
what you you want your kids not to do
yeah and then I think that's kind of how
it is so you get the victims get left
behind in the argument so why are we not
on the side of the kids why why if
there's nothing else in this world for
us to Rally behind what it's you got to
start focusing on the on the cause the
cause and the problem not focus using on
what does this make me look like or how
can I spin this in a way to make me look
better how can and man I'll tell you
what the nonprofit world that place that
is cutro dude vicious I I couldn't even
believe it you know and you know I go to
this point where uh when I do an SF
Mission man like you know I'll be out
there and I'm like man all right we got
to get this bad dude how are we going to
do it all right let's cool let's let's
come together as a team let's plan it
out let's figure it out all right Bam
Bam Bam okay we need to have some
influence out here yeah we're going to
need about 100 grand for for this you
know what I used to do I'd go to this
like a a drro office a dispersement
office I'd go up there and I'd sign out
$100,000 in cash right I like this
window I was like hey I need 100 Grand
sign here I'll come back with my
receipts I'm going to go get these bad
guys right now I got the non I mean you
know freaking SF dude fifth group like
there's I can get BS of money all day
now it's like like where's the all right
cool we got these kids rescue the fact
of the matter is man like I know we know
where these kids are I don't have the
money I'm like where's the window
where's the window with bag so I can go
get the kids right so everybody they're
they
protect they protect their donor base
they protect you know their their
contacts like they don't want to share
them um if there's someone who's curious
about how they can get involved and
help instinctually and naturally people
get into that whole politics thing of
well man you could support them but
we're Green Beret man like who you going
to trust we're veterans man like come on
these guys like they don't know what
they're doing you know like and people
can't help but do that and what it does
is it it breaks everything down and and
I'll I'll talk about that too a little
bit like you you can't in order to
really to to fight against this not
every not one organization is a large
enough or B has the expertise for every
situation so for human trafficking dude
we got to work together we've got to
share donations we give like a recovery
we're not very big and we need we need
more support right but we will give
grants to organizations that are out
doing they can prove that they're doing
stuff like all you guys already in place
why would I spend tens of thousands of
donut dollars to go reestablish a
network connection when you're already
there right let me send uh like one or
two operators out to understand your
operation and make sure it's legitimate
and then we'll Grant you the money and
you report back to us like that's that's
a but dude it's Cutthroat like it is
absolutely Cutthroat I I couldn't
believe it like unbelievable so like
organizations like save the children or
organizations like what like UNICEF what
like you you in a perfect world you guys
would all be working together like why
wouldn't you you guys have a common
cause correct is that right yeah exactly
and and look man I I know for a while
you know I got really into sort of like
the anti-dog fighting thing dog you know
dog skin my my old man ran the the uh
Humane Society of the United States and
that was one of his primary focuses and
I remember there was so much hatred
between PETA the hsus and asbca like
they literally like I would hear them
talk about it and it's like they were
Rivals I was like aren't isn't it the
animals first like aren't you all
literally after the same thing and it
was like and and and I just kept hearing
from it was almost like Rival Sports
Teams and I don't know whether that's
just part of the human but but but for
this issue specifically the movie the
movie has become this sort of like
political lightning rod for for for some
reason right and I'm so puzzled by that
and and look I get it like I'm a
Hollywood actor dude like I come from
like the most left Progressive liberal s
sort of world and there's a lot of those
values that you know I really believe in
um there's a lot that I don't you know
what I mean and I'm an American and I
can believe in what I want to believe in
and and and and I'm I'm I'm down to have
the discussions and sit down with people
who believe anything and I think I could
probably learn from them and hopefully
they hopefully they can learn from me
like that is what's great about being
part of the best country that's ever
existed on God's green earth right so
there's people that that actually do
think that way it's it's so one or the
other now like right right and I guess I
guess what I want to examine kind of
like on both sides that I really wanted
to ask you like I'm just like trying to
figure out about this specifically to me
fundamentalism or being on one side or
the other not only is necessar like in
my mind is the [__] enemy but you are
missing the point because the point is
what's going on with these V here are
these people that are helping here are
these people that are hurting let's
focus on on that let's support these
people and let and let's shed light on
what the problem is do you agree with
that like is that is that right like is
that a fair assessment yeah I I I mean I
completely agree with what you're
talking about is the way it needs to be
right but that that's what happens is
it's it like I was saying it gets away
from the victims and the problem and it
starts talking about the individuals and
you can make anything work nowadays
right and um you know my wife and I had
someone like put this whole presentation
together on us like how we're doing like
trafficking for Richard Branson or
something crazy you know it's like I was
looking at I was like what's the man my
heart goes out to Tim too because like
that something that I feel so passionate
about and and we like as a family like
feel so passionate about and then
someone's going to try to say you're
doing that exact thing for like why you
know like it doesn't make any sense what
is the motivation yeah like why like you
know in my my mind and my heart I'm like
like you know my way last like cuz I I
SU suck at haters I'm like man they get
me so mad like why would they think that
she's like n you got to leave it alone
you know and then Tim that that's it man
he's like a lightning rod and this dude
when I sit there and I talk to him like
me to you in his mind when he's talking
to me all I can think of in his head
he's like got to rescue kids got to
rescue kids got to rescue kids you know
for For Better or Worse he's become like
the face of anti-human trafficking
especially with this movie Y and with
anybody or anything like that the
scrutiny for whatever motivation is g to
come and whatever affiliations or and
when you talk about like Donald Trump in
the Trump Administration like Tim was an
adviser to him Donald Trump was actually
really great when when it comes to uh
policies for anti-human trafficking he
was very supportive of organizations
that were doing anti doing anti-human
trafficking so doesn't it make sense if
their mission and goal is to combat
trafficking to work with people that are
helping you do it you know so now boom
you know he's a he Tim is Trump or
whatever like you know so well I don't
like Trump so I can't like Tim and Tim
is attached to this organization a and
he sits on the board of Ariel so I can't
like Ariel it's like come on man grow up
what are we doing what are we doing
you're spending so much energy on dumb
[__] let's focus on the problem and the
kids let's work together you're not
going to like everything about me I'm
not going to like everything about you
that's right you're GNA have a very
negative life if all you do is focus on
negativity that's right that's right
like come on man like I know we could
beat our heads the wall all day long for
this and that's why I just you I talk
about those anchors man just you got to
cut them I got you know friends of mine
that just trying to you know talk to me
and be like oh you're doing things all
wrong like you know people are saying
this about you and I'm like dude I I
don't got time for that yeah yeah a book
comes to mind and when I was kind of on
my finding myself in purpose and really
connecting and my my wife really helped
me through that one of the first books
she ever had me read was called out
outwitting the devil from Napoleon Hill
and it's an interesting book and um he
actually he sits down much like we are
here and he's conducting an interview
with the Devil
and in the interview he it's called out
withing the devil because he's trying to
figure out the devil's strategy against
humanity it's a really cool book and it
was written years and years ago wow and
at the end of the day the theme comes to
is like the devil doesn't want to kill
you he doesn't he doesn't want to end
you right there he wants to make you
drift he wants to distract you he wants
you to go away from your calling he
wants you to talk about things that
aren't relevant he wants to delude
issues he wants to do all of this that's
when he's winning and that's what we see
here is you got to cut through all the
noise you got to cut through all what
people are saying the stereotypes the
political affiliations the race the
gender whatever it is you got to cut
through that and you got to focus on the
kids that's it that's all there is to it
and and I think I think that it's for
whatever reason or not whatever you
believe spiritually or not there is much
distraction around really great causes
and really great people fighting those
causes and let's let's be real not
there's no perfect human being I've done
terrible things in my life sure me too
if you living a life trying to atone for
things you did in the past and I know a
lot of military people can you you can
probably relate to that too totally man
that's still a great life man that's it
brother what would you say to somebody
who was skeptical of the work you do or
skeptical of Ariel because as this grows
you know maybe you're going to have to
deal with a lot of the things that Tim
deals with what what would you say to
them to to to sort of
explain uh what it is you do what it is
what it is you're about I mean I know
you've already you've already done that
a little bit but what would you say to
to for lack of a better word the
haters go [__] go [__]
yourself no man I would say I'd say you
gota you just you have to eliminate
distraction man and you can't you cannot
believe everything that's given to you
at face value especially if you if
you're one of the people that are
getting your news feeds from social
media platforms and all that stuff like
really read into the problem there's a
lot of great reports that come out the
trafficking and persons report the state
department puts that at every year uh
homeland security has a lot of great um
information on trafficking you know can
rates like different countries and
what's going on inside of the countries
like do the research yourself you know
and if if find a cause that doesn't even
have to be everybody should be behind
anti-trafficking but there's a lot of
things that happen in this world that
contribute to trafficking you know let's
focus on the good and try to not focus
on the negative right and do your own
research most people are too lazy too
but
[Music]
aming hey what's going on everybody it's
John Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf
of both of us and everybody from the
real ones team I just want to sincerely
thank you guys for for for tuning in in
the folks that I bring on the show
they're family to me and uh being able
to tell their stories and bringing you
into their world is something that I'm
I'm just super proud of and uh again
grateful that you guys tune in we've
decided we want to take things just a
step further it's a patreon community
and basically what that means is if you
become a part of this community look I
already boor Bam Bam if you want to
become a part of this community you're
going to be able to hear episodes early
and all that adree and all that good
stuff but there's all this behind the
scenes footage all this stuff that we've
shot um that really brings you into into
the folks that we've had on the show
really brings you into their world live
chats with me and the folks that I bring
on the show to talk about their world
talk about the issues that they're
dealing with about their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon sreal
ones on this website that you see right
there right on the screen that's right
in front of you this whole idea was um
something about building bridges and and
and and bringing people together and um
bringing folks that often don't get the
mic and and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tune in means the
world anyways again thank you uh be good
to each other out there rock and
roll